okay so mental illness
you might think of mental illness as an
autoimmune
disorder of the psyche a mind that turns
against itself right the story
we tell ourselves about ourselves is no
longer
convincing our patterns of thinking
become self-defeating
it's a horrible thing we become trapped
in
negative loops we become oppressed by
patterns
of thought that be that pillage our
inner life both
depression anxiety obsessive-compulsive
disorder
and post-traumatic stress disorder all
originate in the same place a brain
that has become too ordered what
neuroscientist robin carthart harris
calls the entropic
brain theory and so what is needed is a
kind of
shaking of the snow globe that gets us
out of this locked-in
syndrome of sorts right we need to shake
the snow globe we need to be reset right
we need to be
literally dissolved new parts of the
brain
need to talk to themselves think of the
ego the organizing principle of the self
in the mind as the freeway the patterns
of thinking that work
for us that map our world until they
become oppressive until they no longer
work and now we're stuck
on the 405 and it's full of traffic and
we're not moving
and it sucks and so what is needed is
for parts of the brain to start
exploring other synaptic pathways
we need to take side roads we need to be
rethought we need to be remade we need
to be
reborn and this is what psychedelics
promise to do by disrupting the default
mode
network psychedelics literalize catalyze
a shaking of the snow globe they open up
what robin cardhar harris calls
pivotal mental states of heightened
plasticity
and what occurs in these states of
heightened plasticity
is that we can go in and perform an
open-heart surgery of the psyche
what unfolds in those spaces in those
pivotal mental states
is akin to inverse ptsd right it's
entering god mode
it's making deep adjustments
reconciliations right
all contradictions are reconciled and
man has surpassed the gods
right it's a higher level order that
reveals that those contradictions are
actually
reconciled right think of it as the
thesis
and the antithesis and this is the
problem of depression of anxiety
of opposing and conflicting ways of
being in ways
of seeing you are not in congruence you
are tied in and out so you have thesis
and antithesis
and the solution doesn't exist in that
dimension of reality what psychedelics
do is they reveal
not just the thesis not just the
antithesis but
the synthesis which is a higher level
order dimension that again reveals that
those paradoxes actually reconcile
and now you see what you've been looking
for whereas once you were blind now you
can
see right all of your desires abolished
by the plenitude of their satisfaction
it's a parting of the seas moment
psychedelics opened up the space for
that to happen
but how do you create spaces for this to
scale how do you create
spaces where thousands hundreds of
thousands millions of people
can undergo these kinds of
transformations how do you synthesize
the compound so that you can have
efficacy so you can control dosing
so you can create the guard rails for
people to experience these pivotal
mental states where they shake the snow
globe well this is where we need
enterprise this is where we need capital
this is where we need
the psychedelic revolution comprised of
startups that are going to change the
world